[Music]
in the green fields of Provence in
southeastern France lies a unique winery
one operated entirely by French veterans
the domain the Kappa $10 winery has 100
acres of grape vines and overseeing them
all is a la la la una diva heibon
callate la CC pouch no tuna
Lucia who Nevada Nova now it was popular
Jewish duo was a little below that I
could do me this with a tear as universe
I prepared this song Neelam not a the
fields and winery are staffed by
veterans of the storied French Foreign
Legion a branch of the French army
it is unique because it is made up
nearly entirely of immigrants we rely on
share say dr. clay captain ng puso
this was it an issue with Montejo
present up a person's unconscious
nationality mr. Jung ji Oh Millicent
West Indies nerve a relation with OJ je
vais leg salons comma Holly blood watch
you on the grounds there is also a
retirement home that has been housing
and caring for the veterans for over 60
years
miss on what that idea hey I'm a
militant second cat preserve wha no
bliss a SATA Navajo people no Scioscia
we finished lower usual loop region at
want on the presentation a Sandra's own
social vision
another shaky not institutions this one
is on the problem yes aunty we value in
good to her complete avec leur to wash
your family on the veterans work
together in the fields to tend to the
vines and harvest the grapes Hawaii pet
venom a poem a pasta narrative a magic
magic Don Luis onslaught a roll bar
reportage the palaces Yangtze River your
psychology cool the Fed do they share
maybe a leader Hawaii
LaMotta residents also participate in
other activities including bookbinding
ceramics and tending to a uniform Museum
but it's the wine that's their true
passion it shipped all over including to
actively generis on military bases
around the world and they plan to keep
on improving it
rajab chief said I walk through the
valley rotation on the protein core you
can please gl obscene de la mujer
[Music]
you
[Music]